is additional issue with photography
which is not often discussed which is
that guys in particular the brain is a
learning prediction machine I'm not
trying to say that all photography is
bad but there are good data to support
the idea that if your brain learns to be
aroused by watching other people have it
is not necessarily going to carry over
to the ability to get aroused when
you're one on one with somebody else so
you're going to program yourself into
being a Voya yeah or just create
challenges in actual interactions with a
real partner and it's extreme forms it's
a very potent stimulus extreme
pornography extreme experiences like
bungee cord jumping those set a
threshold for dopamine release the
higher the dopamine Peak the bigger the
drop afterwards and it's not that you
drop to Baseline you drop below Baseline
when people are pursuing dopamine Peaks
over and over and they aren't getting
them typically it's because they've been
pursuing that activity far too often and
you're saying perhaps take a break from
that and then maybe an ability for
yourself your system to reset right